quatre collègues notre commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française puisque nous
traitons à la fois des médicaments
matures et des médicaments innovants
pour ceux aujourd'hui ces travaux par
une audition conjointe des représentants
de plusieurs organismes représentatifs
de la profession de pharmacien maillon
incontournable et central d'approvision
de la chaîne d'approvisionnement du
médicament et de dispensation les
pharmaciens étant par définition en
première ligne face aux problèmes des
pénuries de médicaments essentiels nous
savons que vous n'avez pas attendu
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics pour
vous organiser en ce domaine pour n'en
donner qu'un seul exemple je note que la
plateforme des perructures mise en place
par votre profession faites cette année
son dixième anniversaire
et ça fait à peu près une dizaine
d'années que elle est pénurie vont
crescendo
j'allais dire lentement mais sûrement
mais pas si lentement que ça nous avons
recueilli jusqu'à présent les constats
et les recommandations des acteurs
publics de la régulation du médicament
la S la NSM le CEPS la DGS la CNAM ainsi
que d'un certain nombre de prescripteurs
et d'experts économistes Cours des
comptes IGAS notamment il nous est
particulièrement précieux aujourd'hui de
bénéficier de votre recul et de
l'expérience très concrète que vous
tirez des situations que vous rencontrez
au quotidien sur le terrain afin de
vérifier la convergence ou la divergence
de vos analyses et préconisations avec
celle que nous avons entendues au fil de
nos auditions précédentes son présent
aujourd'hui donc autour de la table
Monsieur Bruno Bonnemain président de
l'Académie nationale de pharmacie madame
Karine wolftal présidente du Conseil
national de l'Ordre des pharmaciens
accompagnés
de Monsieur Philippe coat
Coatanéa vice-président
Monsieur Pierre Olivier vario je vous
cherche de regarder
président de l'Union des syndicats de
pharmaciens d'officine lupus Monsieur
Philippe Besset président de la
Fédération des syndicats pharmaceutiques
de France la FSPF accompagnée donc de
Monsieur Denis secrétaire général le
docteur Philippe Meunier président du
Syndicat national des pharmaciens
praticiens hospitaliers et praticiens
Hospitalier Universitaire le mcphe
et enfin le docteur Elis Rémy
la membre du conseil d'administration
des syndicats national des pharmaciens
des hôpitaux alors le signe bref voilà
où le saint bref oui on dit le saint
pour les médecins c'est également je
vais vous aider à chacun tour à tour la
parole pour un propos introductif assez
court assez bref de 5 minutes on ne
parle liminaire que vous veillerez à ne
pas déplacer si c'était possible contenu
de nombre et du témoignage important de
chacun puisque vous êtes nombreux à
avoir répondu à notre invitation ce dont
nous nous félicitons puis madame
Laurence Cohen rapporteur de notre
commission d'enquête vous posera une
première série de questions
donc je précise que nous vous
adresserons à l'issue l'audition un
questionnaire complet auquel nous vous
demanderons de répondre par écrit avant
le 7 avril je précise également que
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage de vend notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 434 et 434 15 du
code pénal je vous invite chacun à votre
tour après tes sermon de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure
monsieur Bonnemain donc je reprends
madame wolftal monsieur vario monsieur
Besset
monsieur Meunier et Madame Rémy
je vous remercie et je vais donc
maintenant vous donner successivement la
parole pour quelques minutes par
organisme ou institution et vous voudrez
bien le cas échéant indiquer quels sont
vos éventuels liens d'intérêt puisque
nous sommes en commission d'enquête et
bien évidemment c'est important contenu
de la sensibilité du sujet d'une
meilleure générale c'est important mais
là le sujet particulièrement sensible
donc je reprends l'ordre d'appel donc
monsieur Bonnemain en premier
merci madame la Présidente
alors je vous avais présenté quelques
diapositives ici et que vous avez en
papier donc je vais du coup aller plus
vite ça sera pas plus mal simplement
pour vous dire si je peux avoir la
diapositive suivante
comment on peut faire avancer les
diapositives je ne sais pas
l'Académie de pharmacie c'est une
organisation qui est placée sous la
protection du Président de la République
comme l'Académie de médecine d'ailleurs
et nous sommes à peu près 500 membres
actuellement au niveau de l'Académie de
pharmacie
sur la diapositive suivante s'il vous
plaît
donc le sujet de la pénurie de
médicaments c'est un sujet qu'on suit
depuis des années puisque on a commencé
à travailler dessus en 2011
et nous avons
rédigé un rapport 2018 juste avant celui
du Sénat d'ailleurs sur la même époque
et nous avons la semaine dernière publié
un nouveau rapport qui est un livre
blanc sur ce sujet donc ce rapport vous
a été d'ailleurs communiqué très
récemment
sur la suivante s'il vous plaît merci
donc les causes de des pénuries sont
aujourd'hui bien connues c'est d'abord
l'augmentation de la demande au niveau
mondial
on estime aujourd'hui que c'est de
l'ordre 5 à 10%, une baisse des prix sur
certains produits de façon excessive la
délocalisation qui va conséquence du
point précédent en grande partie mais
aussi pour des problèmes d'environnement
le problème des appels d'offres
hospitalier est également un souci
majeur et puis d'une façon générale on
pense qu'on manque d'une politique à
long terme sur ce sujet des médicaments
qui puisse être un guide réellement pour
tous les acteurs concernés et puis
aujourd'hui on a fait une gestion plutôt
à court terme des pénuries mais pas
vraiment à long terme alors notre
première recommandation qui est de loin
une des plus importantes c'est de faire
la liste des médicaments indispensables
on l'a demandé depuis 2018 et je sais
que le gouvernement actuellement
travaille activement sur ce sujet mais
ça a mis quand même 5 ans à ce que ça se
débloque Liga a proposé une méthode qui
nous paraît une bonne méthode
pour établir cette liste de 100 à 200
molécules qui seraient
importantes à suivre de près alors ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si on a
une liste
restreinte on peut appliquer de façon
beaucoup plus précise des
mesures à la fois législatives
réglementaire et économique sur ces
produits sur la suivante s'il vous plaît
le deuxième point important c'est de Ren
revoir les enjeux économiques sur un
certain nombre des produits en
particulier ces produits indispensables
la FDA par exemple a montré que en
dessous d'un certain prix on voit
apparaître des ruptures et
c'est donc important de prendre en
compte ce critère et d'examiner vraiment
de façon précise sur ces différents
produits quels sont les produits les
problèmes économiques qui se posent et
quand je dis problème économique c'est
pas uniquement le prix des médicaments
c'est aussi les investissements et c'est
aussi les taxes comme par exemple ce qui
a décidé de PLFSS sur la clause de
sauvegarde qui pénalise et aussi les
produits anciens
diapositif suivantes alors le point pour
nous important également c'est de revoir
la gouvernance c'est à dire qu'il y a
une véritable coordination de toutes les
parties concernées au niveau des
ministères aujourd'hui par exemple la
DGE s'occupe des matières premières et
la DGS des produits finis ça nous paraît
un découpage qui n'est pas adapté
puisque il faudrait avoir vraiment une
coordination interministérielle au plus
haut niveau de l'État donc au niveau du
Premier ministre et de la même façon il
faut qu'il y ait une coordination au
niveau européen parce que tous ces
problèmes-là se vont se traiter au
niveau Européen l'Europe a beaucoup
bougé sur ce sujet depuis deux ans et va
continuer à le faire le ma en
particulier l'Agence du Médicament
européenne mais il faut qu'il y ait une
coordination avec la France et pour
l'instant ça nous paraît assez
insuffisant
la diapositive suivante voilà autre
point important les appels d'offres
hospitalier aujourd'hui il y a un risque
sur
les mégas peloffres qui fait que on a
qu'un seul fournisseur qui est retenu
alors que évidemment c'est un risque
majeur et beaucoup de pays ont déjà
changé leurs habitudes si je puis dire
en proposant plusieurs fournisseurs pour
le même produit
ça peut prendre des formes différentes
mais en tout cas c'est ça l'idée il faut
également tenir compte des productions
qui sont faites en français et en Europe
donc favoriser les circuits courts et
aujourd'hui ça ne fait pas partie des
critères d'appel d'offres
tenir compte également des problèmes de
péremption la FDA par exemple à proposer
de prolonger les péremptions d'un
certain nombre de médicaments il y a une
liste qui existe et puis diminuer les
livraisons en urgence qui dit des
organisent complètement l'industrie
enfin dernier point la diapositive
suivante
je voudrais insister sur le fait que en
ce qui concerne les dromes donc les
DOM-TOM c'est encore pire puisque eux si
je peux avoir la diapositive d'après
eux ont en plus le problème des
kilomètres si je peux dire locaux et par
rapport à la métropole et par exemple je
citais l'exemple de la gravation à
Mayotte aujourd'hui ça devient vraiment
critique puisqu'il leur faut
pratiquement 120 à 180 jours pour avoir
les produits donc c'est vraiment un
problème et ce problème est lié au
transport maritime mais surtout au
transport aérien puisqu'il n'y a aucune
priorité pour les médicaments en matière
de fret
donc ça c'est un vrai sujet actuellement
qui préoccupe beaucoup les collègues qui
sont DOM-TOM
la diapositif suivante voilà et donc il
y a éventuellement des mesures
complémentaires qu'on peut envisager par
exemple l'allongement des péremptions de
des produits finis évitez les les
notices papier qui ne servent à rien
puisque dans les hôpitaux on les jette
quand les médicaments arrivent donc on
pourrait avoir utilisé le QR code
évitez aussi les particularités locales
actuellement chaque pays a des
conditionnements différents on rajoute
chacun des choses sur les
conditionnements ça ne facilite pas les
flux entre pays et moi je pense
personnellement pour les pays les
produits indispensables il faudrait
qu'on ait un conditionnement européen
pour éviter ce problème là
et puis enfin probablement élargir
l'objectif de la stérilisation pour
suivre les stocks au niveau européen
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
merci beaucoup de cette présentation
très éclairante et synthétique madame
wolftals s'il vous plaît
merci madame la Présidente
écoutez je souscris absolument à tous
les propos que Monsieur Bonnois vient
dire ou à peu près pour ma part donc je
représente l'ordre des pharmaciens et
donc l'ensemble des métiers de la
pharmacie à savoir les industriels les
grossistes répartiteurs les officinaux
les Hospitaliers accessoirement la
biologie médicale mais ça nous a
intéresse moins ce matin
et du coup la contribution que je vous
propose aujourd'hui et préparer par
l'ensemble des métiers de la chaîne du
médicament
d'ailleurs mon vice-président qui est
juste derrière moi et lui-même ancien
président d'un grossiste répartiteur
donc si vous avez des questions sur la
répartition il pourra éventuellement
directement y répondre si vous le
souhaitez
ce sujet des pénuries
empoisonne les Français et les passions
tout premier lieu et je pense que c'est
vraiment à eux qu'il faut penser en
premier pour effectivement trouver des
solutions parce que c'est source
d'angoisse mais mais aussi de rupture de
traitement pour eux et donc de perte de
chance dans la gestion de leur maladie
alors aujourd'hui en fait ce que nous
faisons
tout pharmacien confondu mais surtout
les pharmaciens indispensateurs qui
soient à l'officine ou à l'hôpital c'est
de gérer les ruptures on s'organise on
fait au mieux pour compenser substituer
trouver des solutions pour les patients
mais on n'a pas réellement de plan pour
empêcher et à la source les ruptures je
vais pas reprendre les repro les propos
de Monsieur Bonnemain qui expliquent en
effet toutes les causes de ces pénuries
mais pareil essentiel de s'attacher aux
causes
[Musique]
et et sans ça de s'attacher en effet à
une meilleure gestion de ces pénuries
la solution pour gérer les causes elle
ne viendra que d'une stratégie
si ce n'est-européenne Mondial
il s'agit d'une économie effectivement
largement mondialisée et de mettre des
systèmes j'allais dire franco-français
sans tenir compte de ce contexte
international
ne servirait pas à grand chose si ce
n'est mettre des contraintes
supplémentaires sur la France qui
n'existe pas ou qui n'existerait pas
dans d'autres pays donc il est vraiment
nécessaire de prendre en compte ce
contexte international pour agir à la
source de la pénurie et des pénuries et
empêcher les pénuries
en revanche ce que nous pouvons faire au
niveau national c'est effectivement
améliorer la gestion des pénuries et
faire en sorte que les patients en
souffrent le moins
c'est ce que nous faisons tout ce
collectivement pharmaciens
indispensateurs depuis plusieurs années
vous vous l'avez cité madame la
Présidente avec notamment le
déperuptures qui permet un meilleur
échange au moins d'informations
néanmoins je pense qu'on peut aller en
effet encore plus loin dans le partage
d'informations et de gestion des
pénuries
et ça à tous les niveaux de la chaîne
d'abord la transmission d'information
elle est essentielle entre l'industriel
le grossiste l'officinal pour connaître
justement l'état de de ces ruptures
on a parlé des médicaments les MTM les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur cette liste existe mais elle est
pas connue des dispensateurs donc ça
serait utile que les pharmaciens
dispensateurs connaissent les
médicaments qui font partie de cette
liste
il faut que les dispensateurs
connaissent mieux les contraintes qui
pèsent sur les opérateurs que ce soit
les grossistes répartiteurs ou les
industriels et puis il y a des
situations qu'on a vécues qui ont créé
des ruptures sur des situations
monopolistiques
monsieur Bonnemain a évoqué
effectivement
ces sujets là mais c'est vrai qu'on a
des ruptures parce qu'on a qu'une seule
médicament qu'un seul qu'une seule
molécule sur un fabricant sur toute la
France et là forcément si ce c'est ce
médicament vient à être en rupture ça
crée du coup une vraie difficulté donc
il faut absolument éviter les situations
monopolistiques
et puis il faut
peut-être renforcer le caractère
obligatoire du déperuptures puisque
c'est en effet un bel outil mais
aujourd'hui il y a rien qui oblige les
industriels notamment à s'y abonnés et a
déclaré leur rupture auprès des
dispensateurs
voilà donc ça c'est des suggestions pour
l'ensemble de la chaîne ensuite bien sûr
pour les les
distributeurs et les exploitants il y a
des choses à améliorer là encore une
fois la remontée d'information
la capacité de communication auprès de
l'ensemble de la chaîne les en fait ce
que je vais vous proposer par écrit dans
ma contribution ça sera surtout des
éléments très concrets très pratiques ou
pratiques de remonter d'informations
il y a aussi des solutions qui ne sont
pas suffisamment mises en oeuvre au
niveau des dispensateurs comme la
possibilité de faire des préparations
spéciales que ce soit à l'hôpital on est
encore en attente de de quelques textes
mais aussi à l'officine on l'a vu là
récemment avec
l'amoxicilline et la possibilité donnée
aux pharmaciens d'officine de préparer
l'amoxicilline il faut pouvoir aller
plus vite plus loin dans ce genre de
dispositif parce que les ruptures qui
s'installent dans la durée il faut
trouver des solutions rapidement
j'allais dire dans les jours ou les
semaines qui apparaissent la rupture or
la réaction qui permet ces autorisations
et trop longues c'est des semaines des
mois avant de pouvoir soit autoriser des
préparations soi-même autoriser la
substitution par les par les pharmaciens
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je peux vous citer quelques exemples de
comptoir mais
substituer un médicament par un autre
une molécule par un autre c'est c'est
très compliqué alors que pour nous
pharmaciens c'est très simple mais sur
le plan réglementaire
et de d'entendre avec les prescripteurs
c'est c'est quasi impossible et pour des
choses que les pharmaciens savent et
peuvent faire donc il y a des il y a des
outils qui existent sur le plan
réglementaire mais qui sont pas
suffisamment utilisés et pas
suffisamment rapide je souscris
complètement
aux propos de Monsieur Bonnemain sur
l'outre-mer c'est une vraie difficulté
il faut absolument que le fret de
médicaments deviennent une une priorité
et ça c'est vraiment surtout les pays
d'outre-mer
sur le plan de l'Europe il y a en effet
des choses qui vont dans le bon sens
avec les mains et les ce qui est prévu
dans le plan de prévention des pénuries
d'ailleurs la feuille de route du
proposé par la DGS s'inscrit aussi
complètement dans ses travaux donc donc
voilà je pense que en résumé pour lutter
contre la cause des pénuries c'est
vraiment une stratégie internationale
qui nous le mettra qui nous aidera et
puis sur le plan de la gestion des
pénuries il y a l'amélioration encore
soit en termes de communication entre
tous les maillons de la chaîne soit en
termes d'accélération des mesures qui
existent déjà
réglementaires pour justement aider les
pharmaciens indispensateurs à gérer les
ruptures
voilà madame la Présidente
je vous remercie
beaucoup
Monsieur vario
en préambule c'est que les ruptures
elles ne sont pas que sur certaines
molécules qui ont été mises en lumière
ces derniers temps à la moticile ne
paraissentamol et les corticoïdes elles
se font sur énormément de molécules on
en a près de 4000 qui sont en rupture et
ça va surtout sur de médicaments des
anticancéreux des des antalgiques des
antihypertenseurs tous les médicaments
sont un moment ou un autre toucher
ce que je voudrais aussi redire c'est
l'importance et les conséquences qu'on
s'est pénuries de médicaments
au niveau pharmacie on passe entre 6 à
12 heures par semaine à rechercher des
molécules 6 à 12 heures par semaine
c'est du temps qu'on a pas pour nos
patients pendant ce temps-là
au niveau européen le gpua donc le
groupement de pharmaciens d'Union
européenne a estimé qu'on était à peu
près à 7 heures par semaine donc vous
voyez les ruptures en France sont un peu
plus importantes que dans d'autres pays
ce qui explique cette recherche c'est
les conséquences pour les patients sont
bien sûr ce qu'on a dit ce qui sont très
importantes c'est une inquiétude le
stress parfois de la colère des pertes
de chances et des incompréhensions qui
font que parfois même les patients vont
et échapper à leur traitement en disant
puisqu'il y a des ruptures si j'en
prends un jour sur deux ça va peut-être
durer un peu plus longtemps et ils
arrivent à une nonobservance du
traitement c'est c'est aussi renoté dans
beaucoup d'études qui ont été faites au
niveau européen les causes et le
dépénuries sont multifactorielles
monsieur Bonnemain les a parfaitement
décrites je vais pas revenir dessus
juste peut-être une chose qui a été pas
défini ce qu'on appelle l'exportation
parallèle c'est à dire les capacités
qu'on certains industriels ou certains
plateforme d'exporter de sur l'Europe
des médicaments qui sont destinés au
marché français et ça ça appauvrit
terriblement notre notre capacité à
avoir des médicaments
je pense aussi qu'il y a une autre chose
qui est importante c'est que les
industriels ont parfois tendance avant
de leur médicament en direct au
pharmacien sans passer par les
grossistes donc en privilégiant un
circuit qui est plus long et un circuit
qui est plus pénible à mettre en place
puisqu'il faut prendre le temps
d'appeler l'appeler l'industriel pour se
faire livrer alors que le grossiste est
à proximité de chez nous pour des
politiques commerciales qui sont parfois
un peu douteuses donc il faudrait que le
grossiste soit mis dans la boucle plus
vite de façon à pouvoir nous
approvisionner plus rapidement
et puis
la chose aussi qui a été dit par
Monsieur Bonnemain c'est le risque des
appels d'offres vous vous l'avez vu dans
le dernier PLFSS vous l'avez écarté et
c'était très bien et il faut surtout
faire attention à ce qu'elle ne revienne
pas tous les pays qui ont utilisé ce
système d'approvisionnement ont tous
inévitablement arriver à la conclusion
que ça crée des ruptures dans certains
pays on a des appels d'offres qui sont
tous les 15 jours pour éviter les
ruptures ce qui est ingérable et pour
les patients c'est incompréhensible
alors quelle solution on peut envisager
pour mettre fin à ces ruptures comme
comme l'a dit Karine il faut
impérativement qu'on ait une de la
transparence dans toute la chaîne du
médicament on a des pharmaciens qui sont
présents dans l'industrie chez les
grossistes bien sûr dans les officines
et il faut qu'à tout moment quand il y a
une rupture qu'on puisse justifier et
expliquer cette rupture aujourd'hui on
l'a vécu sur différentes molécules c'est
cet hiver quand il y avait des ruptures
il y avait un discours qui était très
très sombre on ne comprenait pas ce qui
se passait si on met de la transparence
de la lumière sur pourquoi il y a une
rupture où sont les médicaments et bien
si on met la transparence on comprend
ici on comprend on peut éviter que ça
rentre ça ne revienne pendant toute cet
hiver on nous disait les molécules sont
produites elles sont parties mais on
savait pas où elles étaient livrés et en
tout cas c'était pas dans nos officines
et pas à disposition de nos patients et
ça c'était vraiment une grande
souffrance parce que quand on voyait des
mamans arriver avec un traitement
antibiotique du doliprane un antitussif
et de la cortisone c'était le combo elle
n'avait rien donc il fallait rechercher
pour pouvoir leur donner quand même un
traitement c'est truc
cette opacité fait qu'il y a une perte
de confiance dans toute la chaîne du
médicament il faut réinstaurer cette
confiance la transparence c'est pour moi
la meilleure chose qu'on peut faire et
c'est ce qu'on a commencé de faire avec
la NSM et qui a été vraiment porteur
puisque on a réussi petit à petit à
débloquer les situations bien sûr le
renforcement du TP rupture qui a un
formidable outil que l'ordre a mis à
notre disposition il faut que se
dépéruptures puisse au-delà d'être
utilisé par les pharmaciens d'officine
de façon automatique soit extrapolée aux
industriels et aux grossistes il faut
qu'on puisse voir où est la rupture et
quand on leur a vu pouvoir voir et
pouvoir l'expliquer aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas on nous on sait qu'on est en
rupture mais on sait pas pourquoi on
sait pas où dans la chaîne il y a cette
rupture
bien sûr les industriels doivent aussi
essayer d'avoir une anticipation de des
besoins aujourd'hui nous disent on a eu
une épidémie qui a été très forte cet
hiver oui c'est vrai mais par rapport à
l'an dernier et l'année d'avant on était
tous confinés donc forcément elle ne
pouvait être que plus importante et
quand on regarde les chiffres on se rend
compte que on est peu ouprou aux
chiffres il y a trois ans donc il y a eu
ce manque dans ce manque d'anticipation
qui fait que on a oui il y a eu
effectivement une grosse épidémie mais
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu
l'anticipation à créer d'autant plus
vite la rupture
nous nous demandons aussi avoir un rôle
plus important au niveau du renforcement
du bon usage du médicament on a la
possibilité aujourd'hui de faire des
trodes des des
tests rapides merci Karim d'orientation
diagnostic qui nous permet de ne pas
avoir à mes usages du médicament prenez
par exemple antibiotique on a
introdangine qu'on peut faire bon il est
pas assez déployé on a d'autres trottes
qui pourraient être utilisés et quant au
Pays-Bas ils utilisent cette rode ils
diminue de 40% de la consommation
antibiotique quand on est en pénurie ce
serait peut-être bien d'avoir ça pour
éviter cette mauvaise usage et cette
mauvaise consommation
bien sûr à plus long terme faire ce que
il avait été proposé c'est-à-dire
réindustrialiser la France y compris
dans les industries de médicaments parce
que plus le circuit est court plus c'est
facile pour nous d'être d'être
approvisionné en cas de pénurie faire ce
que l'on a fait cette cet hiver c'est à
dire fermer certains canaux de
d'approvisionnement en particulier la
dispensation sur Internet
qui fait que on n'a pas on ne gère pas
les volumes donc ça peut partir très
très vite et puis aussi
laisser le circuit au grossiste
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait coupé les
approvisionnements en direct et on
faisait un approvisionnement que via les
grossistes répartiteurs qui eux gérait
les flux c'est simple quand on nous
disait il y a tant de millions de boîtes
qui sont partis et que on interroge les
grossistes en Amel on a un sms j'avais
je savais combien ils en avaient reçu
quand il faut interroger 21000
pharmaciens je sais pas faire donc il
fallait qu'on ait ce circuit qui nous
permette de savoir où étaient les
molécules et où était les boîtes de
médicaments
les préparations magistrales car il n'en
a parlé alors elle porte c'est pas
vraiment le nom de préparation
magistrale parce que la préparation
magistrale c'est une ordonnance qui est
faite pour une préparation pour un
patient donné qui est fabriqué pour lui
là on est dans une préparation qui est
un peu plus large et qui nous permettait
de dispenser plus vite on va pas faire
pour un antibiotique faire revenir le
patient 3-4 jours après quand on aura sa
préparation il fallait qu'on ait déjà en
stock donc il faudrait qu'on ait une
base réglementaire qui nous permet
d'avoir ces préparations non pas de
façon exttemporaine mais immédiatement à
l'officine
ce qui a été dit aussi c'est d'avoir un
tableau d'équivalence comme on l'a sur
certaines molécules en nous disant si
telle molécule est en rupture on peut
remplacer parce que la NSM a dit qu'il y
avait une équivalence par tel autre en
prévenant le médecin parce qu'il est pas
question de le faire dans son dos mais
par contre sans forcément avoir son
accord puisque le tableau et qui va
d'équivalence existe il est parfaitement
simple à utiliser et on gagnera beaucoup
de temps et on évitera aussi de
consommer du temps médical parce que
quand on l'appelle le médecin pour
savoir par quoi on peut changer et puis
qu'on rentre dans une discussion bah là
aussi on perd tous un peu de temps
et puis quand on doit faire quand on
doit faire reconstituer les stocks il
faut bien que tout le monde ait
conscience que les stocks doivent se
reconstituer au niveau des officines en
priorité en premier après chez les
grossistes et en dernier lieu chez les
industriels et pas comme on l'a vu cet
hiver à l'inverse où on a commencé par
refaire les stocks industriels avant de
les libérer chez nous et en fait c'est
nous qui sommes en bout de chaîne et on
doit déjà avoir les stocks voilà je
pense que ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
crise c'est qui on ne doit pas nous
habituer à vivre avec les ruptures il
faut qu'on en sorte
merci beaucoup de cette contribution
monsieur BC oui merci beaucoup beaucoup
de choses ont été dites déjà peut-être
commencer par vous dire que le principal
qui a été dit par mon voisin c'est la
transparence de l'information et
l'obtention de l'information il faut
absolument que nous ayons une vision
claire et prospective avec des datas du
besoin en médicaments notamment sur les
sur ces 200 molécules essentielles qui
vont être listés dans par le ministère
de la Santé
c'est important parce que sans ça sans
connaître le besoin sans savoir de quoi
on a besoin on a du mal à agir et à
trouver des bonnes politiques pour
prévenir en réalité les ruptures j'ai
l'impression
c'est la deuxième commission d'enquête
que je fais la dernière vous souvenez
c'était pour les la faire des masques
qui étaient également une histoire de de
pénurie et de problématique de stock de
départ et de fabrication
je voulais vous donner deux trois
données
de rappel cette année la problématique
des ruptures a concerné les enfants et
c'est ça qui a qui a mis un et moins la
population et qui a mis à juste titre
puisque nous ce sont les formes
pédiatriques qui sont venus à manquer
pour autant on en a consommé beaucoup on
a la consommer sur l'amoxicilline
pédiatrique plus de 11 millions de
boîtes contre 9 millions dans une année
normale 2019 par exemple
et pour le doliprane pédiatrique on a la
consommer 33 millions de boîtes
versus 26 millions l'année dernière donc
on a délivré beaucoup de
conditionnements de ces de ces produits
énormément beaucoup plus qu'une année
normale et probablement on en aurait on
en aurait délivré plus si on en avait eu
suffisamment à délivrer et donc il y a
eu il y a eu donc ces fameuses ruptures
pour que vous compreniez bien le
problème on pourrait prendre l'exemple
de la vaccination anti grippal
la vaccination anti-grippale
nous avons chaque année
30 millions de personnes potentiellement
à vacciner contre la grippe
et chaque année nous devons nous
demander au mois de mars avril combien
de vaccins nous commandons en France
et chaque année on en commande à peu
près 17 millions
parce que en réalité on vaccine un peu
plus de la moitié de la population cible
15 millions il y a une année il y a
trois ans nous avons vacciné près de 18
millions de personnes et nous étions en
rupture
nous étions en rupture parce que nous
avions commandé comme chaque année 17
millions et donc forcément le dernier
million l'avait pas et donc il a fallu
qu'on le cherche en Allemagne il a fallu
qu'on le cherche un petit peu dans tous
les autres pays pour pour arriver à
terminer le stock donc tout se base sur
les prévisions et ça passe c'est pareil
pour tous les médicaments on doit avoir
on doit savoir de combien de médicaments
par classe on a besoin et ensuite avoir
comme solution en fait il y en a au
niveau industriel 2 un stock
de sécurité
qu'il faut forcément être géré un bon
père de famille sinon il est doit être
détruit depuis deux ans on détruit des
vaccins anti-grippes parce qu'on les on
a on a la commandé plus parce qu'on
avait eu cette année de pénurie et donc
ça fait deux ans qu'on les détruit donc
c'est un gaspillage
donc la problématique du stockage et la
promenade la problématique qui a été
décrite de l'agilité dans la production
l'agilité dans la production c'est
évidemment quand on constate une rupture
pouvoir agir de façon très rapide pour
pouvoir avoir remettre à disposition les
les médicaments et cette agilité
évidemment elle est meilleure si la
fabrication se fait sur le sol national
ou européen à partir du moment où ce
sont des problématiques globales et
mondiales de de
production on comprend qu'il est
impossible d'aller du jour au lendemain
demander à nos amis chinois ou indiens
de s'occuper prioritairement de notre de
notre marché à nous
stockage et agilité et ensuite je vais
je vais revenir sur ce que sur ce qui a
été dit sur la gestion puisque je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec avec la
présidente de l'Ordre l'autre ce que
nous faisons nous pharmacien c'est de la
gestion de la gestion de de crise de
pénurie nous avons besoin donc pour
gérer au mieux de l'information
et ça les pouvoirs publics on y
travaille actuellement nous doivent une
information meilleure que ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui nous devons savoir si
le produit va revenir dans trois jours
dans une semaine dans un mois ou dans un
an on n'agit pas de la même façon avec
les patients qui sont en face de nous
en fonction de l'information qu'on a si
on peut si on peut savoir que le produit
va être là dans trois jours on va dire
la personne d'attendre si on si en face
de nous on sait que le produit ne sera
pas là avant un mois et bien on va faire
autrement on va travailler autrement
donc l'information
le deuxième
la deuxième chose qui a été dit
également c'est le bon usage
il faut renforcer la pertinence de la
prescription et parfois là potentiel
vérification de l'adéquation de la
prescription par le pharmacien il a été
il a été question des trodes il a été
question de de dispositif de cette
nature de telle manière à ce que on soit
sûr que le médicament est pris à bon
escient
et donc dans limité par le bon usage la
consommation et enfin dans le cadre du
plan blanc qui est actuellement à
l'étude par le ministère de la Santé
pour lutter contre les ruptures en blanc
rupture effectivement il faut accorder
aux pharmaciens le droit de susciter le
droit de substitution sur une liste
préétablie par la NSM donc ça se
déclencherait par plan blanc
par exemple actuellement nous avons des
difficultés ça a été exprimé sur les sur
les corticoïdes nous savons qu'il est
tout à fait possible de substituer la
prednisone par la prednisolone et
inversement et nous avons
alternativement l'une et l'autre dans
nos dans nos stocks en fonction de en
fonction des approvisionnements bien il
aurait été assez simple de dire ces
produits sont substituables en cas de
pas tout le temps mais en cas de plan
blanc pénurie et dans ces cas-là et bien
faites le et n'attendez pas une semaine
avant de savoir si vous allez ou pas
avoir le médicament
je reprends en 5 points clés
l'information
avec la transparence de l'information
l'information du régulateur et
l'information au plus près du terrain du
pharmacien ça c'est le la base
le stock de départ pour pouvoir faire
face dans les premiers jours l'agilité
de la production
le bon usage
et enfin la gestion de crise avec la
subtilité
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
monsieur meunier
il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont été
dites donc je sais pas j'ai pas fait
j'ai essayé de ne pas faire trop de
redit voilà je souscris bien sûr en nous
souscrivons à de nombreuses
de nombreux items qui ont été évoqués
juste rappeler indépendamment des
conséquences bien sûr pour pour les
patients mais
sur le détournement des moyens
finalement pharmaceutiques
dans une équipe par exemple hospitalière
pour en essai mais c'est trouver des
solutions dans la gestion de cette
pénurie de cette crise qui n'est pas une
crise puisque c'est c'est devenu
finalement faut apprendre à vivre avec
même s'il y en a bien compris que ça
serait bien de pas vivre avec
un titre d'exemple moi je travaille au
Centre hospitalier régional
universitaire de Tours et on a tous les
jours à un équivalent temps plein
informaticien
qui est s'occupe de trouver des
solutions
de négocier de trouver des solutions de
gestion on va dire
pour tout ce qui concerne les tensions
d'approvisionnement et ruptures de stock
de médicaments et dispositifs médicaux
peut-être j'ajouterai que alors c'est
pas l'objet de la commission aujourd'hui
de la Réunion mais les dispositifs
médicaux également en particulier pour
les établissements de santé c'est aussi
une problématique qui est
particulièrement importante dans les
deux cas on va dire médicament etc et DM
ça concerne un certain nombre de
produits d'imatures voilà et de produits
qui sont concernent notamment la
réanimation l'anesthésie voilà les
urgences bon c'est juste une petite
remarque mais il faut vraiment pas
oublier et peut-être que en termes de
stratégie ou de politique je sais pas il
faudrait arriver à essayer de trouver
une espèce de cohérence entre la gestion
des deux types de produits de santé
voilà bon ça c'était un petit un petit
propos introductif
l'obligation de deux mois de stock pour
les fournisseurs pour les médicaments
d'un thérapeutique d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur est-ce qu'elle est
vraiment est-ce qu'elle existe
réellement
est-ce que comment on a contrôlé ça
est-ce que ça se contrôle est-ce qu'on
sait est-ce que il y a un bilan des
sanctions puisqu'il y a des sanctions
qui ont été annoncées
contre nos collègues industriels
finalement est-ce que ces sanctions
est-ce que c'est existe ou c'est encore
des textes qui qui ne sont pas vraiment
appliqués sont-elles effectives sur
cette fameuse liste des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeurs en
effet on peut se poser la question de
son opérationnalité est-elle réellement
connue opérationnelle
et
au-delà peut-être de la NSM je pense que
elle doit être élaborée en collaboration
ou avec les sociétés savantes en
fonction des indications mais on en
revient un peu sur la recherche
d'alternatives et non pas forcément en
fonction alors c'est très pharmaceutique
je sais mais en fonction d'une
classification chimique voilà
ou de leur dénomination commune
internationale la liste devrait en effet
s'orienter ou orienter permettent de
s'orienter vers des alternatives valider
encore une fois je pense par les
sociétés savantes
ce qu'elles ont fait en partie
d'ailleurs
avec la Spar notamment
au moment du covid
dans cette dans cette alors petit point
de détail mais qui n'en est pas
forcément mais qui peut poser des soucis
c'est dans cette liste des médicaments
latéral thérapeutiques majeur sans doute
intégré les antidotes
voilà
les antidotes oui pardon excusez-moi
[Musique]
non mais il faut à mon avis prévenir
il doit bien en exister
vous en existe travaillant dans un
hôpital pédiatrique en effet pour
certaines maladies métaboliques en effet
on a des on a des soucis
alors bon je reviens pas sur le principe
sur les propositions
complémentaires sur les propositions où
il y avait également il va falloir
clarifier qui fait quoi puisque il y a
un COPIL un comité de pilotage ministère
des groupes de travail des gos à NSM etc
va falloir un jour à mon avis un autre
avis simplifié un peu leur opérationnel
et rendre visible un peu les différents
organes de proposition de décision et de
leur suivi je reviens pas sur ce qui a
déjà été dit sur quand même avoir
quelque chose de transversal qui qui
soit fonctionnel et moins pardon du mot
technocratique on va dire
alors votre proposition je reviens pas
sur l'utiliser le plus possible la
production en matière première
production etc de médicaments mais on
dirait que c'est sans doute quelque
chose qui se gère pas uniquement loin de
là au niveau national mais ça a déjà été
dit donc je reviens pas assez doute des
solutions et des choses à accélérer au
niveau de l'Europe ce qui a commencé je
crois être fait
il faut donner les moyens à santé
publique France
de vraiment aider
quitte à peut-être créer un
établissement pharmaceutique national
pour la recherche des ressources et de
solutions de fabrication et de
production
in situ on va dire Europe en particulier
et on en revient un peu cette notion et
qui a été abordée je crois sur la
cartographie un peu de où sont où sont
les médicaments et qui peut produire et
qui peut faire
bon je reviens pas sur l'interdie et
l'Inter
ministérialité mon n'existe pas sans
doute
voilà sur la déclaration des tensions
d'approvisionnement il faudrait qu'on
ait alors est-ce que c'est des
perructures qui doit qui doit être plus
plus on va dire généralisé mais avoir
vraiment une plateforme unique de
déclaration avec une standardisation des
messages
et en effet ce qui a déjà été dit c'est
avoir une information la plus en amont
possible sur les tensions
d'approvisionnement et de leurs qualités
en effet on traite pas en entrée pas une
rupture une tension de quelques jours
de la même façon qu'une tension
à venir plus longue
on peut se poser là aussi c'est une
proposition que nous avions faites de se
poser la question de peut-être que la
sérialisation pourrait nous aider à
cette transmission d'information et
transmission également de savoir où
est-ce qu'il y a des stocks etc
avec peut-être une forme de
régionalisation finalement de de cette
cartographie
bon alors je reviens pas sur tout ça ça
nécessite des moyens informatiques et
vous savez que notamment dans nos
hôpitaux nos logiciels etc et personne
se causent beaucoup
et bon donc voilà je suis un peu voilà
c'était un peu une revendication pardon
d'avoir une casquette un peu syndicale
de de que le Ségur numérique n'est pas
abordé ce type de problématique
je reviens pas sur sur la transparence
en effet concernant
concernant on va dire la partie plus
sonnante et trébuchante
en effet il faut sans doute que qu'il y
ait une certaine transparence des prix
des coûts notamment de la part de
l'industrie
voilà mais ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
pas que l'innovation pharmaceutique
enfin l'innovation thérapeutique pardon
soit le sol financement finalement de
l'industrie ce qui veut dire que
derrière il y a un certain nombre sans
doute peut-être de je crois que c'est
l'Académie qui en a parlé il va falloir
revoir un certain nombre de
détermination de prix
bon je reviens pas sur la d'arrêter les
injonctions contradictoires on en
revient toujours assez à nos problèmes
de de nom de noms
transversalités mais c'est vrai que
d'une part toutes les années sur les
lois de financement de sécurité sociale
il est demandé finalement de faire des
des économies sur les produits de santé
mais à côté de ça on voit bien que c'est
un chat qui qui se mord la queue et qui
est en contradiction avec la réponse aux
besoins croissants et aux besoins de la
population en termes de santé publique
il faut sans doute arrêter des baisses
de prix par classe thérapeutique
est-ce qu'il faut sortir les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeurs de la
clause de sauvegarde c'est-à-dire qui
consiste dans le versement une
contribution à l'assurance maladie par
les laboratoires lorsque leur chiffre
d'affaires hors taxes réalisées en
France crois trop rapidement
voilà on peut se poser en effet cette
question là
je reviens pas sur les achats en effet
la massification à outrance des achats
n'aide pas également sans doute à
trouver des
solutions c'est voilà c'est on atteint à
mon avis des limites et peut-être que
c'est limite elle est encore pire
d'ailleurs pour les dispositifs médicaux
pardon de revenir là-dessus
voilà et tout ça pour dire à ce qu'il
faut pas se poser la question je vous
parle pour les établissements de santé
plutôt d'une régionalisation des achats
je reviens pas sur le multi le
multi-affectation des
achats l'attribution de l'eau
d'attribution de d'achat à plusieurs à
plusieurs
industries mais peut-être qu'on peut se
poser la question notamment ce qui
permettrait aussi d'avoir peut-être une
cohérence sur un territoire à une
régionalisation de ces achats c'est une
question que l'on se pose
voilà et si j'étais un peu iconoclaste
pardon de finir sur cette note un peu
iconoclaste c'est pourquoi ne pas fixer
un prix national et médicaments on va
dire classique pour les établissements
de santé notamment à question également
faut-il s'opposer la question de
l'allongement des brevets c'est je sais
pas si c'est possible mais bon voilà
j'espère que j'ai pas été trop long
merci
merci beaucoup et Madame Rémy
merci madame la Présidente bon beaucoup
de choses ont déjà été dites
effectivement je reviendrai pas sur le
contexte vous allez pouvoir passer
directement la première diaporis
diapositive puisque la mutualisation des
achats dans les hôpitaux vous la déjà
dit on arrive des fois des situations de
quasi monopole on a des vieilles
molécules qui ont peu de fournisseurs
tout ça on vous l'a déjà dit et des
productions de matières premières
délocalisées qui n'aident pas
effectivement à gérer les pénuries alors
pour être plus concret dans nos pays en
fait on a on l'a déjà dit aussi
énormément de ruptures ce que je voulais
dire c'est qu'en fait les causes sont
hétérogènes et la criticité également
puisque les ruptures peuvent toucher des
médicaments d'urgence comme la métallyse
qui permet de faire la thrombolyse en
cas d'infarctus du myocarde donc
clairement ça pose un vrai souci sur
dans les véhicules SMUR par exemple
et on a aussi des molécules avec un
impact thérapeutique majeur j'ai cité
par exemple une logique ce qui est
utilisé dans la prévention du rejet de
greffe donc là on ne peut plus instaurer
de nouveaux patients et c'est très
compliqué déjà d'avoir les traitements
pour les patients déjà en cours on n'a
pas du tout parlé aussi d'un autre d'une
autre façon de gérer les ruptures qui
est le contingentement par les
industriels et ce contingentement il
n'est pas simple non plus alors c'est
sûr qu'on préfère en avoir un peu que
pas du tout sauf qu'on arrive à des
situations compliquées où on est obligé
de choisir finalement être prioriser
pour qu'elle patient on va utiliser et
ça c'est très compliqué pour les
médecins pour nous aussi avec des
patients qui sont souvent quand même en
panique et j'ai cité quand même
l'exemple on en parle beaucoup moins
mais de la léofloxacine qui peut
vraiment être inquiétante pour les
infections
ostéo-articulaires puisque elle a une
bonne pénétration osseuse et finalement
on n'a pas tellement d'autres
alternatives et en plus sont des
traitements longs de 4 à 6 semaines donc
quand on a un patient qui arrive arrive
avec ça et qu'on peut rien switcher
c'est compliqué et puis on a aussi des
médicaments vraiment qu'on peut dire de
base qui sont par exemple les dosettes
de chlorure de sodium ça paraît très
bête mais et ça en plus le laboratoire
est en France donc quand on dit que
peut-être si on relaque relocalise tout
en France on aura la solution bah c'est
pas sûr
et je voulais aussi insister sur un
risque iatrogénique qui est important
dans les services de soins parce qu'à
force de changer de trouver des
solutions on change les dosages on
change des fois les molécules et avec
ces dosages quand on a des molécules un
peu complexes on peut arriver à des
erreurs de d'administration et des
erreurs de prescription et là ça demande
vraiment beaucoup de vigilance de la
part de tous les soignants et ça on en
parle je trouve pas assez et puis
évidemment des médecins qui sont pas
très contents puisque ils ont élaboré
des protocoles thérapeutiques valider
dans les établissements et ils peuvent
pas les appliquer
sur les dispositifs médicaux jouent bon
ça a déjà été dit aussi mais là c'est
vrai que c'est très complexe et nous de
la même façon on a un équivalent temps
plein de de pharmaciens pour gérer les
ruptures parce qu'en fait on a les
médicaments et les dispositifs médicaux
et là c'est plus complexe parce que vous
le savez bien il y a un côté opérateur
dépendant qui fait que une pince de
blocs va pas pouvoir être changée aussi
facilement qu'un médicament pour un
autre
peut passer alors du coup on l'a déjà
dit beaucoup aussi on a vraiment un
problème de visibilité sur les causes et
surtout sur la durée des ruptures et ça
c'est un vrai souci parce qu'on ne peut
rien anticiper en fait c'est quand on
voit qu'on a pas la commande que on se
dit bon il y a un problème on n'est
jamais prévenu alors que les industriels
le savent il faut attendre de les
appeler d'arriver à les joindre pour
finalement avoir l'information et chaque
pharmacien dans chaque pays fait la même
chose donc là c'est vrai que on a un
souci souvent on nous répond délai
indéterminé ça a déjà été dit aussi mais
c'est un vrai souci parce que du coup on
ne sait pas quoi répondre au médecin et
aux patients qui viennent en
rétrocession puisque des fois ça touche
aussi les produits de rétrocession le
manque de transparence on l'a déjà dit
ça c'est vraiment crucial et puis aussi
j'ajouterai le manque de réactivité ça a
été dit aussi tout à l'heure c'est à
dire qu'une fois que les stocks sont
reconstitués on comprend pas pourquoi ça
n'arrive pas plus vite jusqu'aux
utilisateurs
il y a eu des réunions rupture avec la
NSM ou les laboratoires nous dit oui
c'est bon il y a plus de problèmes
d'amoxicilline sauf que nous on en a
toujours et donc on comprend pas
pourquoi on peut pas être plus réactif
une fois que les stocks sont
reconstituées bon la NSM on l'a dit tout
à l'heure elle fait une liste des
ruptures mais n'est pas exhaustive donc
ça nous pose quand même souci c'est très
chronophage pour les pharmaciens c'est
je vous l'ai dit aussi et puis on n'a
pas quand même évoqué dans les hôpitaux
en tout cas c'est très net quand on se
dépanne souvent il y a un surcoût un
surcoût qui est assez monumental pour
certaines molécules c'est à dire que
comme tout le monde cherche une solution
le laboratoire qui va pouvoir dépanner
fait monter les prix ce qui est logique
et on se retrouve avec des surcos quand
même important alors dans les marchés
publics hospitaliers et théoriquement le
le fournisseur qui est titulaire du
marché doit payer la différence mais en
fait là on a que des courriers qui nous
disent qu'avec les problèmes de covid de
surcoût des transports etc on ne peut
pas leur réclamer la différence donc du
coup le surco reste à la charge des
établissements qui je vous le rappelle
sont pour beaucoup pas en grande santé
financière et puis on est aussi
sollicité pas mal par la ville parce que
finalement tout le monde est en rupture
des fois l'hôpital est en rupture un
petit peu après la ville pas toujours
mais ça peut arriver et on a des
patients qui nous appellent parce qu'ils
ont fait 5 6 7 officines qui n'ont pas
trouvé
et c'est pas encadré du tout et on ne
sait pas si on peut faire des
rétrocessions puis de toute façon on n'a
pas non plus tellement de stock voilà
donc quelles améliorations donc on l'a
déjà dit aussi une meilleure
transparence je crois que c'est le mot
clé
une meilleure activité la chaîne
logistique je vais vous la dit et puis
on n'a pas parlé non plus pendant la
crise covid il y a eu des stocks États
qui ont été faits très bien sauf que on
a eu un moment où on avait besoin de
curare il y avait plus de curare parce
que l'État avait réquisitionné les
stocks des laboratoires mais l'État les
avait pas renvoyé non plus ce qui fait
qu'on s'est retrouvé à un moment
vraiment critique où il y avait plus
rien dans nos hôpitaux ou les
réanimateurs étaient vraiment con
c'était vraiment compliqué et il y avait
du stock état mais qui est pas arrivé
jusque jusqu'à nous et le pire c'est que
quand le covid a été terminé on nous a
envoyé tout le stock état et on a tout
périmé
donc là aussi manque de réactivité
la liste des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs on l'a déjà on en
a déjà parlé c'est important par contre
il faut qu'elle soit exhaustive et
régulièrement mise à jour parce que
c'est pas toujours le cas et puis on l'a
dit aussi on aimerait bien qu'il y ait
des propositions validées par les
sociétés savantes sur les switchs les
antibiotiques mais pas que puisque tout
le monde recherche la solution ce serait
quand même bien qu'on puisse avoir une
information
descendante validée où on arrête de se
poser tous la même question chacun dans
ses hôpitaux
et donc je ne crois pas trop à la fin de
la rupture maintenant donc j'ai envie de
dire on pourrait essayer d'améliorer
mais déjà à court terme alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a des péricultures à l'hôpital
c'est pas encore très très implanté il
faudrait vraiment quel que soit la base
de données mais qu'elle soit centralisée
semble la déjà dit avec des
laboratoires des industriels qui jouent
le jeu parce que juste pour un exemple
là il y a ma paix willab qui est une
petite startup qui a fait un logiciel
hospistoc pour essayer de trouver il y a
1000 P8 qui sont connectés et seulement
11 laboratoires ça montre que on est
loin de l'envie d'avoir une transparence
et puis sur le moyen long terme on l'a
déjà dit aussi mais vraiment développer
le bon usage des produits de santé je le
remets là on a quand même en France une
consommation multipliée par deux par
rapport aux autres pays européens et de
3 de paracétamol x 3 ce qui est quand
même pas normal donc on a vraiment
besoin de travailler là-dessus aussi on
a quand même une mode française de
surconsommation on a un symptôme on veut
un médicament je crois que c'est
particulièrement vrai en France et
surtout moi je j'aimerais alerter mais
on savait déjà été évoqué sur
l'observance mais aussi sur
l'automédication c'est à dire que quand
on fait des sensibilisations de
iatrogénie auprès des patients mais
beaucoup nous disent bah moi je garde
les boîtes précieusement comme ça comme
toute façon j'arrive plus à trouver de
rendez-vous chez le médecin j'ai ce
qu'il faut dans le placard si j'ai les
mêmes symptômes je reprends
donc ça avec en plus des gens qui des
fois écourtent le traitement pour se
dire comme ça je m'en garde un peu pour
la prochaine fois enfin il y a un vrai
souci là-dessus et je pense qu'il faut
que qu'il y ait une vraie campagne de
communication et puis on l'a aussi dit
mais évitons les prescriptions inutiles
la stratégie nationale 2022 2025 sur la
lutte contre les antibiorésistances nous
dit qu'il y a 50% des antibiothérapies
qui sont
inutiles ou inappropriées ça pose quand
même une question
voilà je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour ces
polymères déjà très très conséquent et
très complet je donne immédiatement la
parole à notre rapporteur Laurence Cohen
oui merci désolé pour ma voix j'ai une
bringite
elle est un peu meilleure qu'hier mais
pas terrible non plus donc
ça y est j'en ai pris on en a prescrit
bon vous avez déjà répondu à beaucoup de
questions qu'on pouvait se poser
j'aimerais quelques précisions
néanmoins docteur Élise Rémi vous avez
parlé du contingentement par les par les
industriels qui compliquent les choses
est-ce que vous pouvez donner un peu
plus de précision sur sur ce que vous
vouliez dire oui alors en fait c'est à
dire que les laboratoires nous envoient
pas la commande dans son entier c'est à
dire que par exemple on a commandé 400
flacons ils vont nous livrer que 30% de
la commande en nous disant vous avez le
droit à tant de boîtes par mois
donc une fois qu'on a fait la commande
on peut recommander derrière tout le
reste du mois on nous enverra rien du
tout et ça c'est un vrai souci parce que
comme je vous disais on a un petit stock
et on se retrouve à faire des choix a
prioriser avec les médecins en disant à
qui on va le donner celui-là donc on se
dit bah l'amoxicilline on va le garder
pour les femmes enceintes quand un
problème de streptocoque et du coup
quand on a une endocardite à côté avec
des quantités vraiment importantes de
tous les jours faut choisir et ça c'est
insupportable de devoir prioriser et se
le garder pour les bons patients et en
plus on va switcher par un autre
antibiotique qui a un specte des fois
plus large et on sait qu'on va amener
des résistances bactériennes derrière et
ce c'est vraiment un problème très
global et donc le contingentement c'est
c'est pas qu'on a rien mais on a 30 à
40% de notre consommation normale par
exemple
merci donc pour pour ces éléments après
les autres questions c'est finalement
vous avez vous avez parlé d'un certain
nombre de la clause de sauvegarde à
plusieurs d'entre vous en disant que ça
pouvait poser problème est-ce que vous
pouvez aussi expliciter c'est à dire
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez en réalité quel ne soit plus
appliquée qu'elle soit moins appliquée
pas tous les médicaments etc donc donner
un certain nombre de précision deuxième
deuxième élément
dans quelle mesure l'existence de
shortliner ne respectant pas l'ensemble
des obligations qui pèsent donc sur les
acteurs de de la répartition vous pouvez
vous paraît favoriser la parution de
phénomènes de rupture c'est compliqué
avec ma deuxième question pour les pour
les pharmacies pour pour vous alors
c'est docteur meunier docteur Ré my donc
vous êtes au niveau des établissements
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez donc il y
a un certain nombre d'établissements qui
sont des établissements de la PHP tu
imagines
ou pas oui donc j'aimerais non mais
donc j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir au
niveau de la GEPS comment est-ce que ça
ça
fonctionne parce que la jette a des
capacités donc de fournir un certain
nombre de médicaments elle a été très
sollicitée au moment des pénuries est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas en donnant plus de
moyens
financier humain lui permettre de ne pas
seulement tourner au moment des pénuries
mais de manière plus
plus pérenne et à plus un plus haut un
plus haut niveau et je vois là les
autres questions pour ma part vous les
avez vous les avez abordés
peut-être si des éléments pour vous
messieurs c'est sûr le dispositif des
perructures vous en avez donc tous parlé
en disant que c'était un bon dispositif
et qu'il était pas suffisamment
élargi donc peut-être que quelle
proposition vous feriez pour
qu'effectivement finalement tous les
acteurs de la chaîne concernés puissent
utiliser ce dispositif est-ce que c'est
possible en fait dans l'état actuel ou
si c'est pas ou est-ce qu'il y a une non
volonté de ne pas l'utiliser
merci
vous voulez que je complète par les
questions maintenant est-ce qu'il y a
des demandes de parole non donc on va
faire un premier round de réponse aux
questions de la rapporteur allez c'est
Monsieur on va faire dans ce sens-là
parce qu'on est perdu un peu dans le
je vais prendre je vais prendre deux
réponses une sur la clause de sauvegarde
et une proposition sur le dépéruptures
sur la clause sur la clause de
sauvegarde elle est absolument
pertinente pour répondre aux
problématiques prix volumes c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait dans les négociations avec le
comité économique des produits santé et
ça ça évidemment ça a toute sa tout son
sens dans les produits de l'innovation
les laboratoires négocient un prix qui
est assez élevé en contrepartie dans
d'un volume qui est négocié donc donne
de nombre de consommation qui est
négocié avec le comité économique des
produits de santé si le dépasse le
nombre le volume et il est évident qu'il
y a une pertinence à ce que le prix soit
diminué par la clause de sauvegarde en
revanche
sa dispositif ne s'applique pas du tout
n'est pas cohérent avec la politique des
médicaments génériques parce que là
concurrence on met des produits qui sont
des prix qui sont très bas et l'idée
c'est de demander au laboratoire dans
distribuer le plus possible pour faire
faire des économies à l'assurance
maladie et donc leur infliger une clause
de sauvegarde alors que l'objectif est
justement de développer les volumes
n'est pas pertinent donc pour nous le
dispositif devrait exclure les
médicaments génériques de ce fait voilà
donc ça c'est pour la classe de
sauvegarde par rapport au DP en tant
qu'utilisateur puisque la présidente de
l'Ordre va en tant que promoteur du DP
va expliquer le le ce qui peut être fait
demain mais en tant qu'utilisateur nous
notre souhait et que l'information sur
le produit soit au niveau de
l'informatique officielle regrouper en
un seul lieu donc en fait notre nous
avons deux systèmes d'interrogations qui
nous remontent des informations un qui
est gérée par nos grossistes
répartiteurs avec un système qui
s'appelle Pharma
et qui qu'on utilise au quotidien et un
autre de remonter d'informations grâce
au dépéruptures donc c'est un peu
complexe peut-être ou un peu technique
mais notre demande c'est d'avoir
regroupé un seul lieu les informations
qui sont remontées par ces deux canaux
d'information comme ça ça nous
permettrait de savoir le statut du
produit la complexité qu'il y a à s'en
procurer et comment s'en procurer et de
façon simple ou sans procurer donc ça
c'est un c'est un travail que que
j'appelle de mes vœux de synchronisation
entre le dispositif des grossistes
répartiteurs et celui qui a été mis en
place par notre ordre
si vous voulez bien madame leur
rapporteur je peux compliquer compléter
sur le DP rupture ou pas vous me dites
donc en effet alors quelques mots
peut-être de le déperuptures donc le
déperuptures c'est un outil qui permet
aux dispensateurs qui soient à
l'officine ou à l'hôpital de déclarer
les ruptures en fait au sens propre de
la définition de la rupture c'est à dire
quand on arrive quand on a commandé un
produit et qu'on ne l'a pas reçu dans
les 72 heures
donc ça c'est la définition de la
rupture au sens du du code de la santé
publique pour les officines c'est
automatique c'est à dire que l'officine
n'a rien à faire c'est intégrer au
logiciel de comment c'est à dire que il
y a pas c'est c'est intégré voilà donc
c'est automatique pour les pays c'est un
peu différent ça passe par une interface
web donc c'est c'est voilà c'est plus
compliqué mais bon l'outil existe
aujourd'hui il y a 93% des officines qui
sont connectés donc autant dire la
quasi-totalité et 100% le sauront après
le déploiement de la première vague du
Ségur numérique vous connaissez
ce plan numérique
[Musique]
qui permet qui a donné les moyens en
effet aux éditeurs de logiciels de ce de
faire des développements
donc le déperuptures sera bientôt
intégré dans 100% des officines mais
aujourd'hui comme je disais 93%
côté industriel on a 85 laboratoires qui
sont abonnés
ou des perructures donc là c'est une
émerge volontaire de la part de
l'industriel de s'abonner alors vous
allez me dire c'est que 85 mais en même
temps ça couvre quand même 84% des
médicaments dispensés en officine donc
c'est c'est déjà une bonne
[Musique]
proportion des médicaments dispensés et
on a également dit grossistes
répartiteurs qui sont aussi abonnés donc
ce qui représente 90% 98% du marché donc
globalement l'outil des perructures et
et
on va dire largement déployés auprès des
acteurs de la chaîne il reste évidemment
à atteindre le 100% pour pour tous les
maillons
pour que le système soit complètement
exhaustif l'intérêt c'est que évidemment
c'est c'est
fourni par l'ordre donc il y a pas de
sujet j'allais dire de mauvaises
utilisations des données
nous alors dans des particulièrement
attentif à ça
sur des acteurs qui peuvent justement
utiliser des données
de ces flux de médicaments par les
industriels notamment puisque c'est des
données qui valent très cher pour les
industriels et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que je me permets de m'inscrire un petit
peu en faux avec les deux commentaires
qui ont pu être fait sur l'utilisation
des données de la sérialisation pour la
gestion des stocks nous sommes
farouchements opposés
à cette solution pour nous le dispositif
sérialisation il est là pour lutter
contre les faux médicaments c'est une
directive réglement qui a été mis en
place pour lutter contre la
falsification et qui permet en effet
d'avoir une idée des stocks
au début enfin pardon ce qui est mis sur
le marché au début et ce qui est
dispensé mais l'utilisation de cette
base donnée pour d'autres fins serait
pour nous très très dangereuse en termes
d'utilisation des données justement et
de de de vente de ces données aux
acteurs
si vous me permettez je pourrais
répondre aussi sur les shorts liners
tant que j'ai le micro donc très
rapidement donc en fait les short liners
sont des
grossistes répartiteurs qui apparaissent
sur le marché qui ont effectivement une
obligation une obligation de moyens mais
pas une obligation de résultats
et de fait quand il demande une
ouverture d'un établissement
il bénéficie du coup d'un an
de stock de toute la gamme fournit par
les industriels si tu c'est une
obligation
mais comme il n'y a pas d'historique en
effet ils ont ils ont un stock complet
sans sans s'adapter effectivement alors
clientèle le problème c'est que il
disparaissent assez rapidement donc une
fois qu'ils ont bénéficié de cette année
d'approvisionnement
s'il n'arrive pas à pénétrer le marché
bien il ferme ouvre le lendemain sur un
autre un autre site
et par ailleurs ils n'ont pas
d'obligation de service enfin une
remplissent pas leur obligation de
service public comme le font les
grossistes répartiteurs du coup ça
monopolise quand même beaucoup la NSM
pour contrôler ses établissements voilà
alors de là à dire que
contribuer au pénuries bon voilà ils ont
aussi une politique d'export qui est
clairement affichée donc
pas je vous laisse tirer les conclusions
sur les conséquences que ça pourrait
avoir
sur les pénuries
le premier point c'est sur le
contingentement puisque vous avez posé
la question effectivement on est aussi
un contingentement dans les officines
lié à une un contingent industriel vers
les grossistes répartiteurs parce que
les industriels craignant qui a des
exportations parallèles ne livre pas la
totalité du médicament et donc nous nous
avons pas la possibilité de l'avoir
alors le oui le médicament existe parce
que quand on appelle le laboratoire il
me dit oui oui j'en ai votre grossiste a
été livré hier mais je peux pas moi
l'avoir dans mon officine donc il faut
qu'on se bagarre entre les deux pour au
final pouvoir le réceptionner et pouvoir
dispenser au patient et ce
contingentement si vous voulez quand il
y a pas de rupture n'a pas lieu d'être
par contre il faut faire attention qu'il
n'y ait pas d'exportation et pour
répondre à votre question ce short liner
ce sont à mon avis à mon avis eux qui
sont les plus importantes fournisseurs
d'exportation parallèle
bien plus que les grossistes puisqu'il y
a une certaine
de devoir de de nos dispenser les
médicaments à nous et puis concernant le
DP rupture si je pouvais juste faire un
un petit souhait c'est qu'aujourd'hui
quand on je commande 100 boîtes d'un
médicament si pendant trois jours je
n'en reçoit 0 une rupture va être
envoyée mais si au bout d'être aussi au
bout de deux jours ou trois jours je
reçois une boîte la rupture est levée et
j'ai peut-être besoin d'avoir une une
information qui soit juste entre une et
zéro c'est presque pareil mais j'ai
besoin d'avoir une information un petit
peu plus précise
sur la partie sur la question concernant
la GEPS
oui
ça existait avant on va dire et c'était
ça revient un peu les propos que j'ai
tenues tout à l'heure sur faut-il un
établissement pharmaceutique national
voilà c'est à dire que la chef si mes
informations sont bonnes j'espère ne pas
me tromper mais je crois pas me tromper
à plutôt la fonctionner en effet en
période de crise et en travaillant avec
des sous-traitants et en étant pas
réellement un producteur si je peux
parler comme ça donc en effet est-ce
qu'il faut revenir à ce qui existait il
y a quelques années
à en effet un établissement
pharmaceutique type Pharmacie centrale
des hôpitaux pour les plus anciens voilà
oui c'est une question en fait ça fait
partie de des propositions que qui
étaient sous tendues dans ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure
oui juste pour commenter sur la GEPS
c'est clair qu'il y a eu une fermeture
de la jette souhaite claire et non pas
aujourd'hui la capacité de produire
d'ailleurs ils ont très peu
d'équipements en pratique donc c'est
totalement impossible aujourd'hui de
leur demander de quoi de produire quoi
que ce soit ils ont des études des
équipements qui sont complètement
obsolètes
pour revenir au short liner je pense que
effectivement le problème de
l'exportation peut-être une cause de
pénurie le problème c'est que on n'a pas
de chiffres précis de savoir exactement
quels sont les montants qui sont
exportés etc un des problèmes qui se
posent c'est que on a demandé deux mois
de stock aux industriels mais en fait
c'est stocks peuvent être utilisés par
les sortes liner pour les exporter donc
c'est un truc sans fin c'est
complètement incohérent donc je pense
qu'on peut pas demander aux industriels
d'avoir des stocks de deux mois si en
même temps on n'empêche pas les
exportations parallèles de ces produits
là
même en dehors des crises tout
simplement pour maintenir le stock de
départ
sur la clause de sauvegarde je voudrais
quand même revenir là-dessus parce que
au départ la cause de sauvegarde était
prévue pour les nouveaux produits sur
lequel on avait effectivement établi un
prix et en fonction du prix était lié à
un volume le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette clause n'est plus
du tout utilisé de la même façon on le
fait de façon globale c'est pas par
produit donc on dit s'il y a une
croissance du marché en France on
applique cette loi de sauvegarde pour
tous les laboratoires en fonction de
leur chiffre d'affaires c'est aberrant
revenons à l'idée d'origine qui était
pas idiote de dire sur les produits
nouveaux on a des clauses qui sont liées
au volume bon bah très bien mais
l'appliquer du coup à tous les produits
c'est absurde puisque il y a des
produits qui sont peut-être en
croissance au niveau des génériques par
exemple ou des produits anciens mais ça
ne justifie pas la cloche de sauvegarde
vous voyez donc je pense qu'il faut
revenir à l'origine
est-ce que les collègues ont veulent
poser des questions complémentaires
moi je vais je vais quand même poser
deux questions
en complément
dans toutes les sujets qui ont été
évoqués à un très nombreux parce que
vous avez fait quand même
des interventions très complètes la
question du déconditionnement et des
stocks dans les armoires voilà parce
qu'il y a des stocks dans les armoires
des passions et d'ailleurs on a évoqué
la question de l'automédication mais le
problème c'est quand même ces fameux
stocks cette question du
déconditionnement est donc que personne
n'a évoqué cette proposition
j'ai quelques exemples très précis quand
même quand il y a plus que deux
comprimés à prendre sur une boîte de vin
il reste les 18 dans l'armoire du
patient donc il y a c'est quand même un
sujet
voilà la question de la prolongation de
la date de péremption qui a été évoqué
à des reprises qui a un sujet qui a été
pris en main vigoureusement par la FDA
effectivement
certes on sait bien que les dates de
péremption sont liées
à la fois un impératif sanitaire ou de
qualité du médicament mais aussi peu
obéir à à des questions de gestion de
marché en tout cas les a pu pronom
prolonger un certain nombre de dates de
péremption et pour autant il y a pas eu
de drame absolu avec cette prolongation
donc il y a des questions qui peuvent je
finis mes questions et je vous laisserai
répondre très largement
donc voilà cette question là me
semble-t-il et est importante et puis
revenir sur sur les trodes
et en fait toutes ces questions des
tests des tests qui permettent de mieux
prescrire en tout cas de prescrire moins
à l'aveugle quelque part on est quand
même sur un faisceau de symptômes donc
on n'est pas non plus complètement à
l'aveugle dans quand on quand on
prescrit le le traitement
est-ce que vous avez vu une augmentation
voilà de l'usage de ces trottes parce
que je sais qu'ils sont arrivés un peu
plus
sur le terrain et donc
quel point de vue vous vous portez
là-dessus est-ce qu'il y a une améliorer
une amélioration finalement de la
qualité de prescription sur cette
sur cette question et puis alors vous
avez évoqué la question du chlorure de
sodium donc pour le coup il est fabriqué
en France et donc pourquoi pourquoi il y
a une pénurie de votre point de vue à
vous sur le le chlorure de sodium je
pense que c'est les monodoses c'est ça
voilà et puis
la dernière question c'est celle de la
gestion budgétaire de tout ça qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur la ligne
médicament du PLFSS et sur les
arbitrages qui qui sont faits parce que
finalement
c'est un peu cette ligne là qui qui
génère beaucoup aussi de de conséquences
derrière des positives et puis d'autres
négatives puisqu'on sait que ça
conditionne le prix du médicament et le
remboursement du médicament et est-ce
que vous vous verriez des évolutions
possibles en matière de gestion
financière du médicament puisqu'on sait
qu'il y a la lit médicament mais pour
l'hôpital c'est pas c'est pas dedans et
de que donc du coup on n'a pas de
visibilité complète globale du coup du
médicament en France je vous remercie
si vous me permettez je vais prendre en
premier puis mes collègues complètement
sur le déconditionnement votre première
question je suppose que vous pensez à la
dispensation à l'unité
c'est bien ce que vous entendez derrière
des conditions d'accord alors oui en
effet ça peut être une option d'ailleurs
les pharmaciens le font déjà par exemple
pour des classes thérapeutiques comme
les stupéfiants ils le font ils ont la
possibilité de le faire maintenant pour
les certaines classes d'antibiotiques
donc c'est une option qui qui existe
mais qui est en effet peut mis en oeuvre
par les pharmaciens parce qu'ils n'ont
pas encore les outils pour pouvoir le
faire j'allais dire dans des conditions
sereine et satisfaisante de sécurité
aussi c'est vrai que
j'allais dire le on dit toujours le
meilleur déchet c'est celui qu'on
produit pas ou qu'on consomme pas donc
en effet d'avoir dans les armoires à
pharmacie des médicaments qui sont pas
consommés c'est un risque pour tout le
monde mais en premier pour le patient de
mes usages derrière et de réutilisation
du traitement
comment
et en matière de de
paracétamol il y a des trésors à
récupérer oui absolument
on constate nous-mêmes en effet dans les
dents quand on récupère chez des
personnes voilà des traitements les
consommations sont donc là il y a un
aspect économique je laisserai mais
mes confrères dire ce qui pourrait être
envisagé il y a déjà des mesures qui qui
pourraient être qui sont mises en place
qui permettent aux pharmaciens de ne pas
dispenser quand on quand on interroge la
personne savoir si elle en a à la maison
etc mais mais là on se heurte un refus
souvent du patient mais bon ça c'est la
première chose c'est déjà dispensé faire
en sorte de dispenser que le strict
minimum
et ce dont le patient a vraiment besoin
il y a quelques pistes au-delà de la du
des conditionnements c'est
c'est d'adapter les conditionnements
préparés par les industriels aux
prescriptions en fait les laboratoires
[Musique]
pour un certain traitement avec une
certaine posologie prescription durée de
traitement et ils adaptent leur boîte à
ça
sauf que au cours du temps la HS par
exemple émet des recommandations qui
font évoluer c'est durer de traitement
et c'est posologie du coup le boîtage ne
se trouve plus
on adéquation avec l'autorisation de
mission sur le marché donc en fait il
faudrait déjà à mon sens être plus
souple sur
sur les boîtages et les les mises à
disposition par les industriels parce
que très honnêtement il n'y a rien de
plus sûr en termes de sécurité que les
boîtages fournies par les industriels il
comporte les notices les toutes les
alertes sur les la vigilance sur la
conduite la toxicité enfin je veux dire
c'est une information qui est complète
vérifiée et certifié etc si le
pharmacien des conditionne en en fait il
faut que sur les petits comprimés qui
vont plus être dans la boîte qu'il a
donné au premier patient moi il faut
qu'il rajoute toutes ces informations et
c'est pas très simple très honnêtement
c'est pas très simple pour garantir là
aussi la sécurité pour le patient qui va
se retrouver chez lui avec trois quatre
comprimés qui sont sortis d'une boîte
pour lesquelles il aura plus toujours
l'information donc c'est si on choisit
cette voie là il faut donner les moyens
aux officinaux de fournir l'information
qui va avec les trois quatre comprimés
qu'il aura sorti d'une boîte il y a une
autre piste aussi c'est encore une fois
je reviens sur cette solution qui est
d'ajuster les prescriptions parce que
bon je je
pense mes confrères me confirmeront mais
le nombre de fois où on voit des
prescriptions qui sont pas conformes en
fait ni à la même ni aux recommandations
HS et qui nous oblige du coup à donner
la boîte supplémentaire dans laquelle on
va prendre que de comprimés
il faudrait que nous on puisse ramener
la prescription à la juste
et quand on appelle souvent le médecin
on nous dit non non moi je veux sept
jours et pas six alors que la mm et la
HS c'est 10 c'est 6 jours mais le fait
de rajouter un septième jour et bien ça
nous oblige à donner une boîte de plus
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait pas là aussi
conditionner le 7e jour vraiment à
l'état du patient dans six jours déjà
revenez nous voir dans 6 jours si
vraiment il vous faut un septième jour
on verra ce qu'on fait mais de d'emblée
donner une boîte supplémentaire parce
que le le prescripteur choisi cette
option là c'est pas c'est pas voilà donc
en résumé des conditionnements oui
pourquoi pas mais donner vraiment les
outils aux pharmaciens pour sécuriser
toute la dispensation
encourager le pharmacien à
limiter la dispensation aux besoins au
strict besoin du patient pouvoir ajuster
les prescriptions et puis travailler
avec les industriels pour avoir des
conditionnements qui soient plus
adaptées en effet à des prescriptions
différentes
oui je voulais intervenir sur les
péremptions parce que je pense que c'est
effectivement un sujet important d'abord
il faut savoir que c'est un sujet
réglementaire on ne peut pas aller
au-delà de 3 ans c'est la règle
européenne donc les industriels
appliquent cette règle
le problème c'est que évidemment
beaucoup de produits pourraient avoir
une péremption bien plus longue
évidemment et c'est pour ça que la
démarche de la FDA a été de dire votre
péremption et les trois ans mais on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de produits
sont parfaitement stables ils ont fait
cette liste qui est publiée sur le site
de la FDA et qui permet aux
professionnels de santé d'aller au-delà
quand c'est nécessaire en particulier en
cas de rupture donc voilà la démarche
maintenant si on demandait aux
industriels leur avaient bien sûr il
pourra augmenter la péremption le
problème c'est que derrière ça demande
une usine à gaz parce qu'il y a pas
d'autres mots pour garder les produits
en stock pendant admettons 5 ans je vous
garantis que c'est un volume
considérable donc ça pose un problème
aussi pratique pour les industriels
d'aller au-delà des trois ans de façon
en routine disons mais de façon
exceptionnelle bien sûr on pourrait et
c'est l'intérêt de cette liste de la DA
concernant l'aspect économique vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure il y a juste
dans les diapositives qu'on vous
laissera en Backup vous verrez par
exemple que en 2010 la part des
médicaments d'enodam était de 14 % et
actuellement il est de 11 % malgré
l'augmentation des besoins puisqu'il y a
eu vieillissement de la population et je
parle là hors
covidiquement la population les
innovations importantes et chères en
général et le donc il y a vraiment un
problème on peut pas baisser la part des
médicaments dans mon dame alors que on
augmente les besoins c'est pas possible
il y a un vrai sujet
merci beaucoup je voudrais revenir sur
trois points donc je pars redire tout ce
qui a dit Karine sur la dispensation à
l'unité il faut savoir que s'il reste
des médicaments chez les patients c'est
en grande majorité parce qu'ils ne vont
pas au bout de leur traitement donc
c'est pas forcément parce qu'on a
dispensé une boîte qui était plus
importante c'est parce que au bout de
400 jours ils vont mieux et ils arrêtent
donc même si on avait fait une expansion
à l'unité ça n'aurait pas changé grand
chose et en toute état de cause tout le
reste je manque car il a dit c'est
parfaitement on avait mis une
disposition avec la CNAM qui était dans
la dernière convention qui était la
dispensation adaptée qui était la
capacité que les pharmaciens avaient de
dispenser pas forcément la totalité des
traitements dès lors que le il y avait
une posologie variable 1 à 3 par jour de
paresthétamol et on discutant avec le
patient on avait cette possibilité la
CNAM la reconnu la remise dans la
nouvelle convention par contre pour
l'instant de la part redéployé c'est
vraiment dommage parce que ça nous
aurait sûrement permis d'amortir pas mal
les ruptures de paracétamol
concernant le chlorure de sodium je
pense que c'est ni l'eau ni le sel qui
manque en France mais c'est plutôt les
petites pipettes en plastique voilà je
pense que enfin en tout cas c'est ce que
nous remonte des laboratoires et par
rapport au trod donc qui ne sont pas
fabriqués en France
nous demandons à pouvoir faire le
maximum de trottes et vous avez
introduit dans la PPL ris la capacité
quand les pharmaciens de faire tous les
3D je vous en remercie vraiment parce
que c'est dans ce sens que que l'on doit
aller avant quand nous voulions faire un
trot c'était une bagarre de plusieurs
années pour avoir le droit de faire un
trou dans leur sauf le trop de covid on
a le droit de le faire très vite mais
autrement il a fallu grimper et pouvoir
donc aujourd'hui les trottes sont
limitées prenez par exemple une un
trot qui est la glycémie capillaire en
dehors de la semaine du diabète on peut
pas faire donc sauf à étendre la semaine
du diabète à l'année du diabète et le
renouveler tous les ans ce serait bien
qu'on a le droit de faire certains de
faire tous les trois donc oui on en a
besoin oui on peut le faire et quand on
explique aux Français le but du Tron
quand on a fait le trop de covid
personne nous a dit est-ce que j'ai
besoin d'un antibiotique il savait que
c'était un virus il savait quand il me
dit qu'il serait inefficace il y a eu
aucune discussion donc il faut pouvoir
objectiver les choses quand on quand on
objective et qu'on explique ils
comprennent et quand ils comprennent une
fois de plus et bien ils acceptent
beaucoup mieux
je vais j'ai peut-être me lancer dans
dans la régulation du prix du médicament
puisque vous m'avez nous avez aussi
questionné sur le sur le budget
médicament dans la dame
on est arrivé au bout d'un cycle d'un
système qui a commencé dans les années
2007 à peu près et qui a déjà duré
quelques années de trop et on a on
ressent les les causes les conséquences
aujourd'hui sur la problématique des
médicaments essentiels dans
l'arsenalthérapeutique mais qui sont qui
sont des produits donc anciens avec
perte de brevet le sujet suivant
l'état la représentation nationale ont
voulu stabiliser le budget à louer aux
médicaments en France depuis 2007 et a
demandé aux industriels et aux
régulateurs de dire de toute façon vous
avez un budget constant quand vous avez
des innovations qui rentrent vous devez
les les payer en réalité par une
diminution des produits qui sont sur le
marché depuis longtemps de telle manière
à ce que les produits qui rentrent soit
financés par les pros par la baisse de
prix des produits anciens on arrive à
une situation où pour citer deux et deux
extrêmes le médicament le moins cher de
France c'est le Lévothyrox 25 un
médicament extrêmement important vous
avez eu entendu parler du du lévothyrox
dans la longtemps il y a eu beaucoup il
y a eu peut-être même une commission
d'enquête sur le Lévothyrox il y a
quelques années le niveau de 25 il a un
tarif de
8 centimes d'euros la boîte 38 centimes
pour fabriquer le médicament le mettre
dans le blister le mettre dans le dans
le packaging mettre le la notice ça
c'est 38 centimes d'euros voilà le
médicament le plus cher de France c'est
le train zik il c'est un médicament qui
traite une maladie osseuse rare pour
52000 euros la boîte ce sont des flacons
c'est un traitement c'est un traitement
aussi Qui est qui est nécessaire
moi à titre là pour le coup de de
pharmacien et de citoyens
je trouve étrange cette écart de prix
entre 52000 euros et 38 centimes d'euro
le sur des traitements qui sont qui sont
majeurs les deux qui traitent des
pathologies majeures les deux un ancien
à nouveau certes il faut payer la
recherche certes il faut payer le il
faut payer le l'innovation mais en tout
cas il est maintenant impossible et donc
la représentation nationale il y a des
étudiants un groupe d'experts qui est en
train de plancher sur le sujet mais on
ne peut plus on ne peut plus
continuer une politique de financement
de l'innovation par les baisses de prix
des produits d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs anciens vous ne pouvez plus
faire baisser le prix du lévothyrox de
38 centimes à 35 centimes et de toute
façon ça va rien financer du tout
on est arrivé au bout du système et donc
il va falloir avoir des des il va
falloir réfléchirer et innover pour
pouvoir
dans notre pays pouvoir accéder aux
innovations mais avec des tarifs
peut-être plus raisonnables ça je
voulais le dire mais mes confrères ont
répondu sur la dispensation adaptée sur
les trodes peut-être un mot peut-être un
mot pour vous dire que
il faut véritablement une politique de
généralisation de ces trodes parce que
le bon usage passe par eux
la porte d'entrée elle est médecin ou
pharmacien
et les sujets
le passé au Journal officiel il y a
trois jours des protocoles de protocole
de délégation sur la cystite et sur
l'angine avec l'utilisation de 3D en
officine il faut aller un point plus
loin dans le dispositif parce que l'idée
de
l'idée de le faire uniquement dans des
lieux où il y a un exercice coordonné
prive la moitié des Français de ce
dispositif alors qu'il serait beaucoup
plus
utile d'envisager de
protocoliser comme il est fait comme la
HS l'a fait pour ces deux pathologies
pour l'ensemble des officines de telle
manière ce qu'on sache après protocole
si on délivre ou sont des livres pas et
on envoie dans le on envoie vers le
médecin ou pas on donne le médicament ou
pas en fonction de l'arbre décisionnel
qui est très clair qui a été fait par
leur autorité ité de santé
mais je voulais juste compléter sur le
déconditionnement pour vous dire qu'on a
quand même des conditionnements
différents déjà aujourd'hui entre la
ville et l'hôpital c'est à dire que
quelquefois je le souvenir des EPO mais
il y en a sûrement plein d'autres on a
des boîtes unitaires nous à l'hôpital
quand la ville a des boîtes de 3 ou 6 et
que du coup d'emblée s'il y a pas besoin
d'autant d'injection c'est alors que le
conditionnement il existe
et à l'hôpital c'est vrai qu'on en a des
gros conditionnements on fait du des
conditionnements tout le temps nous
puisque c'est des boîtes de sang
doliprane par boîte de sang chez nous
donc on consomme beaucoup aussi et donc
voilà mais il y a quand même un vrai
sujet là-dessus puisque les industriels
ont déjà des chaînes de fabrication
différentes parce que pour eux
inconditionnement de plus effectivement
c'est beaucoup d'investissement mais il
y a quand même des choses qui existent
déjà
en fait il faut aussi distinguer
peut-être dans le 10 conditionnement ce
qui est du traitement chronique et du
traitement aigu le traitement chronique
des patients qui sont sous hypertension
ou diabétiques ça sert à rien de lui des
conditionner sa boîte de 30 comprimés
puisque voilà il en aura à vie donc
voilà donc traitement chronique
traitement aigu traitement aigu donc on
est fait pour pour les antibiotiques je
voudrais dire quand même aussi que dans
toutes les situations de rupture qu'on a
eu récemment le déconditionnement ne
nous aurait pas aidés par exemple
l'amoxicilline pour les enfants c'est
difficile sur un sirop de faire du des
conditionnements donc il y a plein de
situations où de des conditionnements ne
changent pas
la solution la différence entre
l'hôpital et la ville c'est que
l'hôpital en effet vous avez des
structures qui vous permettent de
reconditionner en sachet ni dose ou avec
avec des machines qui permettent
effectivement de reproduire un
conditionnement externe sécuriser ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans nos 22 000
officines en France on a on n'a pas de
quoi reconditionner de façon
en toute sécurité avec à nouveau soit
des notices soit des étiquetages soit
des soit des conditionnements ce que les
pays peuvent faire mais à l'officine
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué en tout
cas pour les 22000 officines
je voudrais juste
faut que je fasse très court merci
Madame ma présidente
ou voilà de remarques la première je
suis pas sûr
pardon Présidente j'ai oublié de vous
rappeler c'est pour ça que je vais pas
être objectif je suis effectivement
sénateur en CDD mais pharmacien
d'officine en milieu rurale dans un
secteur à 20 habitants km² dans la
moyenne les patients font 14 km
aller-retours pour venir dans une
officine donc la question du stock elle
est essentielle nous sommes en
commission d'enquête pénurie de
médicaments ce qu'on veut savoir c'est
comment on évite que ça se reproduise je
ne crois pas un instant au des
conditionnements faut qu'on arrête de
croire que c'est la solution l'alpha et
l'oméga des stocks en pharmacie d'abord
parce que
arrêtons de culpabiliser qui que ce soit
et il faut quand même rappeler que la
galénique à ses règles et que si on
commence à des conditionner des formes
moraux dispersibles ou je ne sais quoi
d'autre un moment donné on va voir
quelques soucis parce que si la
sensibilité à la lumière etc etc donc
s'il faut qu'on rappelle la galénique on
le fera avec grand plaisir
commission d'enquête pénurie médicaments
faut qu'on apporte des solutions on l'a
vu sur un certain nombre de positions
plus de flaconnage parce que les verries
sont arrêtés il faut consacralise avec
les industriels la production de
flaconnage en matière en période
peut-être printanière pour qu'à
l'automne effectivement on arrête de
faire des verres pour les cantines mais
qu'on fasse des flacons pour recevoir
les décidines ou le sommetmazine s'il
faut donc je crois qu'il y a c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on ait comme apport en
tout cas il faut des stocks de sécurité
qui les finances comment on assure la
pérennité moi je rabâcha chaque réunion
de la ce que je suis très inquiète sur
la répartition parce que en milieu rural
la répartition à un moment donné va nous
abandonner il faudra qu'on aille
chercher nos caisses sur le bord de
l'autoroute ça c'est l'arrêté de cette
année donc c'est c'est là où il faut si
on veut un accès à la santé pour tous de
façon équitable dans ce pays qui est des
mesures prises dans ce sens là merci
pardon d'avoir été long
oui je voulais juste ajouter un quelque
chose au niveau des prix on a parlé de
du problème de fixation des prix il
faudra revenir à l'historique
historiquement on fixé les prix en
fonction du PRI et ça ça date des années
70 et un moment du prix de revient
industriel et à un moment donné on a
décidé de le faire par le service
médical rendu et l'amélioration du
service médical rendu
je pense que à mon avis il y a une
commission qui travaille là-dessus mais
il me semble que ce serait logique de
revenir pour les produits anciens à
cette logique de Pairi donc de revenus
industriels donc on des investissements
et que par contre pour les nouveaux
produits et les produits chers en
particulier qu'on regarde vraiment le
l'amélioration du service médical rendu
mais je pense que avoir le même système
pour les deux produits deux types de
produits c'est pas une bonne idée voilà
ce que je pense
je vous remercie beaucoup de voilà de
tout ces échanges y compris sur le des
conditionnement voilà comme quoi les
avis sont variables d'un pays à l'autre
et d'une profession à l'autre et suivant
comporte un regard de régulation de
dispensation ou de prescription ou de
fabrication donc il faudra évidemment
tenir compte de toutes les propositions
et les adapter à la réalité et donner
leur juste place dans les propositions
donc je vous remercie d'apporter des
réponses écrites
circonstanciés au questionnaire que nous
allons vous adresser et puis de nous
faire parvenir tout document que vous
souhaitez
utile ou nécessaire pour éclairer nos
travaux et je vous remercie beaucoup
voilà de cet échange de toutes vos
propositions de voilà de la justesse de
bien de vos propos sur une question qui
est encore une fois n'est pas neuve mais
n'est pas traitée
je vous remercie